alors enrico la chanson la plus engagée
sans doute celle qui est signé par
dabadie qui s'appelle le voyage et qui
dit je ne l'ait pas fait ce voyage des
fous montbard et le battage alors
évidemment on voit bien de quel voyage
il s'agit c'est ce retour en algérie
cette partie en 69 kg est jamais
retourné et une fois quand même pour une
mission de l'onu vous avez survolé
constantine en avion c'est vrai on m'a
fait la surprise et pendant le voyage il
est passé au dessus de constantine il a
il
mais c'est l'attitude quoi et puis j'ai
reconnu le paysage de constantine et
autour besoin va sentir j'ai bien
reconnu quoi c'était j'ai vu la vallée
du hamas j'ai vu le pont suspendu
ça m'a fait quelque chose quoi terrible
terrible mais oussama un petit peu
consolé d'avoir fait ça un petit peu on
avait parlé ici de ce voyage
magnéto serge vialle et chantez vous
devez aller chanter après que je vais
chanter voilà un centime le 18 mars
et puis partout en algérie voilà alors à
constantine annaba par bonne pleine
scène tizi ouzou et alger dont
constantine c'est pourtant là faut pas
oublier oran et alger c'est le 27 on
suit une tournée en algérie et après on
peut dire qu après 38 ans donc il ya 38
ans que j'ai quitté l'algérie s'est
jamais retourné et la boucler et en
quelque sorte de clé si c'était quelque
chose que je n'aurais même pas imaginer
en rêve
et puis qui viendraient pseudo m'arriver
comme un comme quelque chose c'est même
pas historique ces messieurs nick wey
soumissionner c'est assez beau nom
indique puis sa valeur non non pas du
tout ça m'impressionne pas du tout je
crois que les gens ont une fausse
opinion de la réalité des choses
je pense que tous les gens qui naissent
de rands vrai leur maître gilet
pare-balles aussi parce que à chaque
fois qu'on l'ait on est condamné à mort
ça bien mentalement à le tout
quel déconneur alors vous y allez en
plus pendant la période de l'aïd donc la
fête du mouton qui la fête du pardon
dans la dans la région musulmane et vous
partez avec 200 autres juifs d'algérie
qui étaient là-bas à l'époque et qui
s'activent je pars avec 200 enfants
d'algérie de nous deux confessions et
nous allons reconstruire un pont entre
l'algérie à la france un pont qui a été
un petit peu coupé pendant longtemps
pendant 40 ans et puis voilà je suis
fier d'être le leader de cette
merveilleuse histoire
cette nouvelle page de l'histoire que
j'ai chanté depuis 40 ans au moment où
je vous avais parlé ici vous alliez
partie à cet été-là clair c'est vrai
qu'il était prête mais qu'ils étaient
prêtes et puis d'un coup grande
polémique née en algérie
comme je le dis dans la chanson qu'on
les a écrits ou jean loup dabadie et que
je revendique aussi des fous mon barrer
le passage
bon c'est tout point - je ne dis pas ce
qui va se passer dans l'avenir
vaut mieux pas en tout cas mon cas
personnel n'a aucune importance par
rapport à ce que je souhaite en algérie
souhaitent que l'algérie devienne
pluriel je souhaite qu'elle soit une
véritable démocratie qu'elle retrouve la
paix civile et que tous les enfants
d'algérie soit reconnu et toutes les
cultures y compris les pieds noirs les
harkis les berbères les judéo arabe
enfin tous les enfants d'algérie et là
franchement ça sera là oui mais là est
la vraie fête ça arrivera de toute façon
même si c'est pas de mon vivant c'est
obligé que ça arrive
non
vous avez déclaré lundi qu en parlant de
l'annulation de ce voyage au dernier
moment à dernière minute se disant pour
des raisons techniques
vous avez déclaré ça va plus c'est mal
quand 60 de oui parce que en 62 j'ai
subi l'histoire comme des mis des
millions de gens qui ont créé la même
histoire que moi et c'était une blessure
quand je voyais mes grands-parents être
déplacée comme ça où les jeunes c'était
différent parce que on avait l'espoir
d'un nouveau monde
c'était l'amérique pour nous la france
mais mais cette fois ci la cicatrice qui
commençait à se refermer avec cette
grande espérance de retrouver de cette
réconciliation de tous les enfants
d'algérie qui ne s'est pas fait
là ça m'a fait mal ça m'a fait mal et
encore une fois je vous répète c'est pas
grave ce qui m'est arrivé à moi
personnellement un jour je ferai
abstraction de ma fierté personnelle
si c'est pour réussir cette grande
espérance
merci à tout le monde moi même me faire
un cadeau
méline est ce qu'on peut apporter la
guitare des nôtres
enrique aurait secoué le 6 mai linh
enrique aux prises juste me faire adieu
mon p juste un petit bout de adieu mon
pays
comme chez vous un petit beau ou pas de
ce côté-là génitales
j'ai quitté mon pays j'ai quitté ma mère
ma vie ma christoly se traînent sans
raison
j'ai quitté mon soleil j'ai quitté ma
bible leurs souvenirs se révèle bien
après soleil
saumon penny perdu des villes blanches
que je ne
des filles que j'ai jadis prony mais du
bord du bateau qui met monnier du quai
une chaîne volot a claqué qu'on me fou
et j'ai longtemps regardé
ses yeux bleus qui lui et la mère les a
noyé dans le flot du regretté
il ya tout cela des et pourquoi pas
nous et moi
je veux pas d
pour vous
mais le dernier jour
il veut garder
carrière dans l'élite après l'olympia du
1er au 9 mars prochain
espace adéquat 17 18 iphone fait
l'olympia ben oui j'ai jamais compté
voilà comment mais c'est ça fait oui je
crois mon second 17e olympiques c'est ça
l'art 40 ans de carrière 40 ans de
mariage or là vous ferez pas parce que
suzy votre épouse a perdu sa mère il
n'ya pas longtemps hermance sa mère et
puis sa mère est décédée un vraiment à
la suite du grand chagrin qu'elle a eue
de perdre s'applique il ya quelques mois
qui est la soeur de suzy on a passé vrai
très très dur mais enfin ça c'est la vie
de personnel de chacun sait c'est comme
ça et je salue le courage de suzy qui
est malgré cette épreuve seuils de
remonter le courant pot pour moi pour
les enfants pour les petits enfants et
on l'entourent de façon à ce que nous l
a encouragé qs exceptionnel exceptionnel
vous êtes combien quand vous vous
retrouvez là les macias là ça fait un
paquet donc entière les événements
macias les amis alors maintenant enrico
on va remonte